and welcome to hannity this friday night
now tonight we begin by stating the
obvious uh democrats they have been
lying to our faces for years you know
remember president trump's border wall
remember when democrats called it racist
and dangerous and un-american wow look
at this what a turnaround a 180 joe
biden is now attempting to finish the
wall but he's trying to do it in secret
we've got a full report we will expose
it coming up also tonight another live
from democrats remember when they told
us that society would be better and
safer and more equitable if we just got
rid of cash bail and defunded police
departments
violent crime is now spiking rape and
murder and assault are all on the rise
and african americans are being hurt the
most but new york's district attorney
doesn't care we're going to show you how
new york city's but one city run by d.a
alvin bragg and is now turning that city
into a playground for criminals but
first we begin with another big lie from
democrats and that is a piece of
legislation that they are calling the
inflation reduction act it's anything
but let me be clear it does nothing to
reduce inflation it will increase
inflation it is a 400 billion dollar
green energy boondoggle it will raise
taxes dramatically and by the way you
will pay the cost of it it will increase
costs for every american across the
board in other words it will make
inflation far worse so why on earth
would self-proclaimed moderate democrat
joe manchin support this bill well
apparently he wants to be welcomed back
i guess into the washington swamp and
their polite society and obviously he
thinks that the people of west virginia
they won't notice or they won't care or
they won't blame him for inflation and
rising energy costs but the people of
west virginia are not stupid joe manchin
is to blame here and so is every other
democrat that spent trillions of your
dollars to appease the climate alarmists
save the planet cult with new green deal
socialism
now of course this includes joe biden
himself the biggest liar of them all
this week more horrible news around
every turn every day this week we got
bad economic news but according to joe
life's great
he won't even admit the reality that
we're in a recession he won't even admit
that rising inflation is a crisis which
by the way continues to get worse now
one economic indicator tracked by the
fed came out today
the personal consumption index just
jumped to a four decade high seems like
everything's a four decade high and if
you think inflation is bad now just wait
until china invades taiwan sadly the
president is doing nothing to coerce
china's malignant dictatorship and and
prevent yet another global conflict
china just threatened america on the
phone call yesterday with the president
and told us better not be playing with
fire what did joe biden do nothing today
they threatened to assassinate the
speaker of the house nancy pelosi blow
her plane out of the air if she dares to
visit taiwan what did joe biden do
nothing so with the president of the
united states content on doing nothing
and cowering in fear what's stopping
china from invading or reunifying with
taiwan or pumping even more fentanyl
into our country or stealing more of our
intellectual property or never taking
the responsibility for the global
pandemic that they caused hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else